Resident Evil Revelations 2 episode 1
came out for last and current consoles
as well as PC on Tuesday the 24th right
Peter that's right that's right and even
though a lot people haven't playing
through the campaign something a lot of
people haven't been showing is the raid
mode which is actually pretty sweet I've
been hearing it's like it's just an
excuse to have a lot of fun shoot a
bunch of zombies and other enemies like
that it sounds good yeah very different
from the main game so we're gonna jump
into it right now and kind of just see
what it's all about this is like the
main hub that we're looking at right now
when you first enter it yeah so
basically red mode is you as a virtual
avatar like someone is controlling the
world and they want you to sort of go
through these really tense fearful
situations so they can test you it's
kind of one of the themes in the story
of the game but really this is just an
excuse to shoot a bunch of stuff and one
thing you do first is you choose a
character you go up to that creepy
mannequin with no hair after you meet
characters in the the main game they get
unlocked in raid mode so I'm gonna go
berry here one of the good things you
can do is customize weapons you earn new
weapons and raid mode by finding
treasure chests that have an
unidentified item you also seem to
unlock those after is that like after
you get to a particular level sometimes
you yeah you'll unlock like a new slot I
think occasionally if you get to a level
they will give you a weapon as well
these are some skills that you can use
or essentially just like buffs more or
less what kind of skills are they this
the only one I have right now it
essentially just gives you like a higher
rate of damage okay
and well my favorite thing is you can
customize gestures and course there's
like your typical you know where you
know just like go ahead or let's do it's
hot I want to find whoa
or somebody farted it was me these are
all super awkward one of my favorite
ones okay giddy schoolgirl check that
one's okay okay this one he is just
loving life and this is the worst
version of the robot I've ever seen I've
seen a lot of robots but that is not the
robot
I think last example I'm so show cute
little Japanese apology
Domenic all right but those are really
the only important when you're playing
with other people what you can do
currently on consoles online or locally
but PC has to wait for an update
it sounds beneficial to me a robot after
it's a successful murder attempt so
you're basically going in two different
rooms and kind of just killing
everything in it once you do that then
you go to the next room is that way it's
certainly there's really areas I
administer lis rooms but yeah she's like
a general like area that and zombies
sort of like a peer and you have to kill
enough to get to the next area
ultimately to go through enough to get
to the goal one thing you can you get in
this game is currency like little gems
for beating all the levels or for
beating a level you also get life
crystals for completing daily challenges
so I'm gonna do that and what live
crystals do is they let you is that
little blue heart symbol they let you
revive yourself in the middle of a
mission right so if it's particularly
hard you really want to get through it
you can do that
there is a micro transaction version but
every day you have a chance to earn more
and you start with like 10 or something
so this is the one that you haven't
played today right exactly
all right let's do it let's do it
changed no that's fine yeah and this is
like very different from the main game
and it's the third time I've said been
yeah what are the motivations to playing
this instead of this story mode just
pure pure action just an excuse to not
worry about like the story or like
getting in trouble or like yeah Moira
it's really cuz like you know you try to
conserve ammo in the main game and like
you obviously shoot a bunch of stuff but
it's a lot of stealth parts in the game
as well you're actually not trying to
shoot people
well sometimes yeah I mean ultimately
you don't want to have to waste
ammunition but even the stealth sections
you find yourself like kind of stuck in
a corner of you're like well there's no
way out but to shoot this is just
straight run-and-gun so just rate run a
gun I'm gonna switch to a different
weapon it starts off a little team but
as you progress through the little
section but there's more and do you
recognize this area from the levels in
the campaign no not yet so this is
episodic game right right episode two
isn't even out yet right this is that a
four total right right so some of these
areas are from episodes that aren't even
available what's you know actually kind
of weird I think
is it just a sneak peak or you feel like
you're getting spoilers by looking at
levels that haven't even been seen in
the game yet I feel like it's a little
bit of a spoiler so okay yes boiler on
well it's just you know like the game
takes place on an island and you don't
really know how big it is or what's
what's there until you see that stuff so
to see like okay there's this place
where it has snow you know that like you
haven't seen the extent of everything so
here is where I would use the area key
but I haven't killed everyone yet once
you kill everyone in an area you just
automatically get it you don't have to
like pick it up or find it he's left you
got did you start with some herbs it
looks like yeah and you get bonuses for
not using them so and right now this is
pretty timid the the daily challenge
stuff is in my experience so far not
that difficult
okay got the area key and that's just
kind of it's funny it's kind of just
meant to keep you coming back every day
totally and it's not successful do you
find yourself wanting to come back yeah
like second day but you've been able to
do that I'm enjoying revelations too as
it is and this is a fun way to like kind
of keep playing once you're done because
the actual episodes only last a few
hours yeah but there is way more content
to explore in RAID mode so you'll be
spending way more time than you would in
the actual episode itself yeah I mean
it's certainly built that way and it
depends on how you feel about this sort
of stuff but you know I don't really
like to think of it as like oh it's
written you look on action it's like now
it's just a little action game that's
really you know what it is these guys
are super slow I know this is this is
actually a little bit too easy but we'll
jump into a mission that's a little bit
more difficult after I beat this what is
cool in this mode is that enemies can
get like status buffs or like elemental
properties so they're like made of ice
and like maybe they have an ice shield
and you have to like kill one zombie
who's casting that on everyone which is
pretty interesting and definitely makes
it more difficult where's the area key
you have to find the air here you get it
after you kill everyone you get after
you kill everyone in the area see you
now in prison so alright so that guy was
elemental he was yeah a freezer sure
what other kinds have you found besides
that guy standard incredibly slow one
that's a snail zombie I don't remember
so far the most of them have been ice I
think there is like poison 1 or like us
all motion thing have you encountered
anything else besides a'm because
they're like dogs or anything else and
raid mode so far I've only seen like
humanoid stuff but these zombies are
really like slow there are other zombies
in the game did not culling of zombies
is kind of inaccurate actually but yeah
you know there'll it just like infected
and afflicted but yeah so they called
them in the story mode there they're the
afflicted we're gone actually yeah but
see have you flipped it though are
really fast and strong right and you
know like running after you and there
are other guys that are kind of like the
enemies from left 4 dead that looks
would was called remember no there's
just the fat guys yeah yeah how good are
we at our jobs that we don't remember
yeah I gotta get the one what explodes
on you I always had weird names for the
ones in left for dead like neck was the
really long one girl spitters they
called them they had these gross
horribly long necks it was really creepy
alright so this is the end right here
but I definitely want to kill more
enemies so sometimes after you get to
the end you can go back and find others
because the game is giving you a chance
to go the extra mile here we go you can
see in the top right corner it tells you
how many are left so it's not like
you're just like wandering aimlessly
like well I really hope I got everyone
like you can definitely tell you said
you get bonuses I think they called
clear medallions when you actually feed
it without ever using an herb what are
those good for so those essentially earn
you more currency towards the end I
think there's something else that they
do I haven't played enough raid mode to
get absolutely everything down
okay I'm done here but especially
essentially what you're doing is you're
trying to just do the best that you can
in a game rewards you know gesture oh
[ __ ]
I'll do it yeah well play one more
mission I haven't seen gestures in the
world all right I want to make sure we
pick good ones let me go sign them real
quick
oh so you get to pick new gestures for
the new level each level you get to it
sends you back to that today I had that
world in I was leveling up oh yeah like
I said these are really quick five
minutes of peace all right so we're back
in the central hub we're gonna go check
out a different
we got a re get our character in but you
know I kind of want to see a few other
character gestures okay I look at
something else besides yeah nobody likes
Barry more than us I think we can say
but there's probably other I'd like to
see some of the other characters and
their gestures also it looks like so you
carry over your skills and your guns did
no matter what character you pick yeah
yeah you can use all the weapons you
unlock you can then use it actually you
know what before I do that I'm gonna
unlock some more guns can I do that yeah
alright give me those guns evaluate so
these are the things that you find in
the level in the treasure chest right at
a record store I like it yeah the way
that they did this you get a look
compatibility pack you get an idea of
what you found but you don't know the
specifics until you identify it okay so
the thinking there is like well I
already have a good machine gun I don't
really need to spend money on that so
you can sell it if you don't want it or
you can keep it is this kind of like a
Diablo thing where it's always better
always better to just find out what it
is before you sell it you know you
should always figure out what it is
first I do because look how much
currency I have you have a hundred and
fifteen thousand coins you're loaded and
this cost five hundred so I might as
well like you spend money to deploy on
de missions which is why you might think
oh I need to save some but I haven't
seen a mission that costs enough to make
me worry about that yet did you get
anything good let's go find out she's
trying to breeze through that and so you
get back to the customers alright bring
up where those gun
are worth DJ that because the record
player okay I got a magnum only got six
bullets but it's pretty freakin strong
look at that firepower 1,800 compared to
133 or 90 that's a huge it's pretty good
and you can sell them shotgun you can
sell them if you want I don't want but
but these ones are for Peter yeah uh
yeah you go with you
unfortunately I can only bring two
weapons with Claire but that should be
okay give her some new gesture let's see
what she's got yes pected 100g one
standard one guns in the air is that
what I think it is I think she's asking
no no I know she's doing guns in the air
but I don't know what the end I'd like
to see just a few more
and he's apology alright these are both
Japanese apologies I love her knees come
together oh why thank you
don't fall
nobody laughs like that she looks like a
really shitty Sims character now keep in
mind this only cost six dollars she
blows her mind yeah these could all be
labelled drunk this is Hawkeye like that
look at her face yeah I get down look at
her feet they're just roasted floor
she's good she's actually a pretty good
dancer
know what else we got alright we could
assign two more so why don't we that's
almost not enough she's having a seizure
Oh Ginza that's that looks an
appropriate the final pose she strikes
alright so make sure there's all saved
okay good
well that alone makes the game worth it
that's what I'm saying all right all
right so let's pick a date these are not
the daily messages a regular man she's
just regular old stinking Chinese you
guys alright and the king of Chinese
sure okay so you pay some your currency
to reload your weapons before getting
into a match okay but again it's paying
so little
yeah it's considering how much money you
have it almost seems like currency has
no point at this stage because you can
basically just you might say I'm flush
with cash yeah you're so flush I've got
money in the bank all right all right
we're yet Oh like we are in a school
spoiler is a school in the game I mean
look what's behind me no one yeah a
little bit of a bummer only because I
like to investigate the area and in the
story and kind of see them for the first
time Oh totally
but on the other hand if you're doing
raided missions it would be really dull
to do them in the exact same area
every time Open Sesame
hey friend I'm going to throw a thing in
these dudes Grenada also to go back to
earlier boomer up top
boom me being away ok looks like the KFC
low okay so he is this yeah give him the
day finish it off
yeah pretty no more ah oh yeah oh you're
just a boy is that a bunch of goop just
a bunch of goo hate that goo
we're in a lecture hall no oh there they
are late to class glad to see you're all
taking your education seriously who's
the boss now they have so much you have
so much time before you can actually
have to do anything about that
look how slow I know this is like one of
the least action-packed actually the
last one was at least action-packed oh
good to see you thought you dropped out
god damn it do I really not have your
you still students just keep enrolling
I'm very popular clinician oh come on
thank you spraying wait wait wait wait
wait wait there's one more student down
there
no Billy Billy you're something on your
face wait wait wait wait wait Billy wait
the joke still works okay good really
it's interesting they're like spaced out
till one it they won't spawn until you
kill the ones that you need to kill yeah
in the area at the time
who's that is that the Dean on the wall
that's Dean Smythe's no it's Munoz
Benford did a shitty job all the
students are dead
hi guys tall he is not in high school
behind you this is a better area yeah I
guess that's another thing that's cool
with these open rooms is even if one
isn't very interesting it's pretty much
one minute or a quick shotgun to the
dome before you get to go to a new area
and kind of figure something else out so
I like the fast-paced nature of it just
to keep going I got the key already Dan
are they at though where they at though
moving on come on Claire that's the end
but I got four more enemies to kill do
it you want to get that perfect oh yeah
we're not oh good one idiot
you made that guy look like a total jerk
let's be honest he made himself look
like a total jerk yes for it all right
let's go punch a thing come on come on
go for it ready Rudy finish you're so
cool Peter Brown thank you I know
all right so mission cleared
that's rainbow you're not a clear
medallion it's a small party red mode
yeah there's a whole lot of stuff there
but you know what for six bucks which is
all that the episode costs yeah so you
get this with the episode you get the
campaign which how long it took you to
finish that I mean dependent you can
repeat it on different difficulties and
lock things and make your character
stronger so first time through two to
three hours per episode and then if you
want you can go back and play more cuz
there's plenty of reason to I think oh
yeah then this is and then hours of fun
and Rain Man with daily challenges all
right well thanks for talking me that
manner I think we should end on our
favorite Claire pose I'm gonna do the
robot one because that was the best I'm
gonna okay
all right my neck